is a tuesday morning it is time once
again for
the rose test yes here are the roses
let's
break it down again yeah here's the deal
if you didn't watch yesterday we've got
five groups of roses as you can see all
purchased on saturday five different
places
two um national distributors online
distributors one a local grocery store
and then two local florists and the idea
is to see which one lasts the longest
and if it's worth your money for
valentine's day which is not that far
away so here's the trick though we don't
know what's what nope we know there are
five shops we can show you the list here
of the five places that we got them from
but we don't know which one's which
you're going to find out right along
with us there you see the name of the
places here
we're starting though heather we're
starting to kind of guess craft where we
think some of these are from uh-huh
we're pretty confident because this one
right here in front of me heather that
one's a little nervous for where this
one's hurting for certain right now it's
struggling yeah i don't know if the
camera can show this one right here
it's a little it's a little hard and
hard pressed to survive right now oh
gosh so let's hope it didn't cost too
much we are going to reveal the prices
tomorrow so at least we'll know how much
they cost and then on friday we'll tell
you which one
so when you're making your valentine's
day plans you'll know where to go
exactly like i keep saying get creative
find maybe something else other than
roses yeah i don't know
here's a thought just a thought 6 16
we'll have the rose test all week long
first nate and cherry over to you